my question is going to be where where
do you think he is
well i mean well we knew he was in china
at one point so so we should say the the
law suits the civil war suits 2016 in
the us
and then in 2018 the u.s and malaysia
both file criminal charges against jhola
um and at the same time the prime
minister of malaysia najib razak loses
power in an election in malaysia and
he's
he's arrested um and i think his najib's
verdict by the way might come out
today um in asia or or tomorrow or
something like that so
um jolo is told by the prime minister to
get out of the country
and he goes to china um and this is this
is where the story gets very complicated
but it's just unbelievably
interesting he's able to do deals so
najib at that point is still
uh prime minister is before he loses
power in the elections and he's able to
do these infrastructure deals
with china and malaysia and they steal
even more money this is not the one mdb
floor this is just
post 1mdb to use to to fill some of the
holes
and he uses the a friend in kuwait who's
the former prime minister's son
excuse me um and he's able to he's able
to sort of
keep doing deals and uh china has not um
said anything about it but we got
minutes of a meeting we know that jolo's
protector in china at one point was a
guy called sun lee jun
who was a head of the domestic security
forces
that guy has just been um arrested for
corruption in china
um without any comment by the by xi
jinping's government so
what we we believe there's sort of a
clearing of house going on in china
about this but jolo is still there
and of course he's a very useful pawn
for anyone who who holds him
right because you know he knows all this
stuff um
about where the money's gone he still
controls a lot of money too
and he's still paying his lawyers um
which we don't understand how he can do
but he's still paying his lawyers in the
u.s
millions of dollars so so uh any idea
where he is in
china or just kind of the the general
ideas just
in china somewhere well this isn't a
joke he was definitely in wuhan at one
point we have we have sort of
intelligence it was in wuhan this is
before the um
the virus started um since then to be
honest
that would be very early this year or
actually late last year since then i
don't know exactly where he is but um
i i'm not sure whether he can travel
it's possible he can travel or until
recently he's been able to travel into
the middle east
the uae to because a lot of people are
trying to cover this up right for
example
um the uae was involved involved in this
the
shakeman saw the owner of man city uh uh
football club soccer club in the u.s
in england um he his boat the 650
million dollar topaz which is now called
the a plus
was partly financed with money from
stolen from one mbb so
there's no there's a lot of people who
don't really want this you know uh
to be raked over and so he's possible
joel can travel to those countries too
on private jets
but i imagine the chinese authorities
are keeping him pretty
much in their sights right um because
they want to control him
yeah absolutely and it's the thought
process when you say he's got control
over money is that something that
it's just nobody really understands but
he's obviously paying some of these
bills that we know are expensive
or is it something where um we think
he's literally walking around with
duffel bags of cash or
kind of how do you think that somebody
who uh is really this like international
uh wanted man uh still has control over
money and can kind of do some things
well he moved money into chinese yuan
for sure because when he was trying to
pay off some of these
corrupt deals i just mentioned they were
moving it around by icbc which is a
chinese bank in yuan
and the reason to do that is to avoid if
you do a dollar transaction you could
end up
getting caught by the correspondent bank
right it has to be
it has to be checked and so he's
basically been frozen out of the u.s
system
but he's i think he's still got access
to thai baht or
chinese yuan and all of all these
currencies he tried to buy a bank in
i think the komoros islands at one point
uh post all this coming out right so he
could control money
and obviously china's becoming a bigger
bigger player in the global economy and
so
you can do stuff with iwan and you and
it's and it's not you know it's it's
to a degree a bit more internationalized
than it used to be even though they
still have a closed capital
capital account right um so that's
that's i think how he's operating
um but it's incredible to me that the
big question i have is cobra uh
cobra and kim right his lawyers are
they're they're a big law firm shillings
in the uk
they're getting paid money um they cobra
and kim uh
had to file a form a pharaoh form which
is
to show to the us government that
they're lobbying for him and they're not
they're not obviously paid by him
they're paid they were paid by a thai
guy a thai friend of jolos
but i don't understand how you can say
well you know
we know that this money is not the
proceeds of crime you know lawyers
everyone's everyone's allowed a lawyer
right that's uh and joel has not been
proven guilty you know he's only he's
only been he hasn't
turned up to face the charges but he
hasn't been proven guilty so that's fair
he needs a lawyer
but but for when it comes to um taking
lawyers taking money to do lobbying to
send letters to try to stop a book being
published like a billion dollar whale
i mean then i have questions about well
how do you how are those lawyers proving
that the
the money was not tainted um extremely
extremely
interesting situation yeah the part to
me that i think just blows my mind is
you've got a guy who
uh it almost seems in some weird way uh
has a very tainted reputation but has
become emboldened
after the scam was uh uncovered
like you you almost get like one of
these weird things where you could
imagine this guy is like bragging about
the fact that there's a book written
about him
and he just forgets the part of like
that it's written about a scam right
like it's almost like the fame and the
the egotistical nature of all of this
is driving him to do more and more to
some degree it sounds like for some of
these stories
well as well his favorite book um we
learned was
uh the book about mark rich so mark mark
rich was the oil trader
who ended up getting um uh charged in
the u.s and he lived his life out in
switzerland on the shores of lake
lugano in a luxurious villa and and i
think jolo sort of saw this guy as his
model in a way
and and rich was pardoned by bill
clinton on his last day in office
um and so i think joella really saw that
as his end game to get a sort of a
pardon
um and as i said the story is super
complicated but
making it even more complicated the the
the party of najib razak the former
prime minister who's been
arrested um is is now coming back to
power in malaysia
and so there's this idea that maybe all
the charges will get dropped in malaysia
if that party solidifies its grip on
power and then jolo might be able
might actually be able to come back to
the country i mean it's not
not unbelievable i mean it's a very very
corrupt place